und jetzt wird einfach eine komplette
stadt errichtet
löste meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft command die letzte folge
ist jetzt schon ein paar tage her
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich liebe
diesen schieder so sehr altes ich habe
mir gedacht mir wurden wieder sowas von
viele und coole command zugesendet und
ich habe jetzt gesagt dass diese folge
grundsätzlich erstmal freitags kommt und
dass so viele kommen vielleicht auch mal
zwei mal die woche war larissa hallo
schafe und hier ist sie alt ist sehr
sehr schön aus jedes sie dann alle leute
die ihn haben wollt mir wurden wieder
richtig coole command zugesendet
wirklich von stadt bauen überall
luftballons über büchern alles mögliche
richtig coole sachen deswegen würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr das video bewerten
würde nachdem es euch komplett
angeschaut habe weil es ist blöd wenn
man dann wieder bewertet bevor man es
komplett angeschaut hat das verstehe ich
und wir fangen direkt an mit kummer war
nummer eins ist dieser command der
wurden mit zugewinnen von sbs 6 der ist
so aufgebaut ich werde euch in dieser
folge nie die ganzen command zeigen und
auch nicht erklären command nummer fünf
ist einfach der aller guides und geht
über 2.400 zeichen wochen wirklich
zusammen pick und das macht irgendwas
und das ist erst mal seinen kummer und
damit man ein bisschen reinkommt damit
man die türkei durch geht los wieder mit
dem command und das ist ein feuerball
und das dach ein schwein das dort
explodiert das total pedal drückt mir
drauf und wir kriegen einen feuerball
er ist ein unsichtbares schwein drauf
mit einem satten und ich kann dem
bogenschießen hallo gegen tiefe so und
es stimmt einfach direkt gallardo
richtig dumm alter diese commander er
selber sehen ist ein schwein ausgegeben
hallo es liegt einfach weg explodiert
und ist tot so gar keinen sinn
das ist einfach nur jetzt ihr bruder
marius das ist jetzt mal sei nochmal
cornelius hongkong beauftragt vom juni
wo kommt er her risiko geschaltet er war
der kirche da oben und da ist s p hat
das ist ob man ey ich verstehe es aber
nie nikon ist alles klar wird hier
kommen wir mal dass herr cornelius hier
auch auf jeden fall drin bleibt und
seiner kleinen kleinen besonderen
kleinen wir sind ja ich glaube die
minecraft kunst vielleicht wird mit
einer weitermache mit nummer freundlich
weiß nicht ob mir das gerade hört aber
draußen ist ihnen so ein typ der wieder
mit den träumen seiner trompete rung der
verzieht sich gerade
ich war echt drauf und dran die polizei
zu rufen ja hallo hier und hier blatter
ist so ein typ der tropfen die ganze
zeit vor meiner wohnung und so richtiger
spaß ist ich verstehe nicht wie menschen
so hobby los sein können aber na ja wir
machen weiter mit kummer nummer zwei der
wurde mir zugesendet von moment von dem
wir damit zugesendet mal hier steht
sogar drin von levon 30 ich glaube sein
ingame name ist level 30 und sonst heißt
der levels steht er hier level klm 30
und wenn ich jetzt einfach mal drauf da
bekomme ich ein buch und das heißt
command pack ich weiß zwar nicht warum
ist command pack das heißt also wieso
der command effekt bewirkt hat und das
ist ein buch wo es möglich ist seit der
1.8 meint er dass sich auf diese blauen
teile beispielsweise draufklicken kann
und dann werde ich direkt irgendwohin
teleportiert also wir lesen uns das buch
mal durch dass es recht kurze zeit fünf
seiten hey hier eine kleine anleitung zu
einem buch überall blaue schrift zu
sehen ist kannst du mit der maus darüber
fahren und du kannst auch klick mich
jetzt auf die clique steht im chat
beispielsweise du lernst schnell jeder
eigentliche befehl wie du siehst klicke
ich drauf ganz viele nachrichten
übereinander stapeln und wenn ich jetzt
einfach weitergehen seht ihr schon das
war es dann auch eigentlich schon zu
guter letzt kann ich nur sagen dass ich
keine ahnung habe wie ich das noch
weitermachen sollte aber ich glaube dass
das in der 1.8 nicht weiter möglich ist
ich habe circa eineinhalb stunden dran
gesessen aber es hat sich anscheinend
gelohnt dann kann ich nur noch danke
sagen dass du dir mein buch angeguckt
hat mit was heißt es mit vielen grüßen
matschie grease oder was bedeutet genau
diese abkürzung also er hat mir quasi
ein buch gemacht wo es möglich ist wenn
ich auf dem buch auf texte drauf clique
dass es mir hier im text angezeigt wird
das ist auf jeden fall richtig cool
finde ich richtig interessant das buch
an sich ist natürlich nicht interessant
oder was hast du dazu kommt es nicht
der chef habe auf jeden fall nicht so
mein ding aber kann schnell das thema
schimmel und ein stück kommen elias
nehmen jetzt nehmen für das hat schon
ganz schöne wucherpreisen ok haltbarkeit
doch das gilt sogar eine ganze fülle ich
finde sowas cool für adventure maps wenn
man dann quasi so ein buch hat dann kann
man darauf klicken werden dann
irgendwelche nachrichten angezeigt wo
muss ich als nächstes hingehen und so
das ist schon interessant
damit kann man richtig coole sachen
machen und jetzt kommt das album an drei
freunde der trommler kommt zurück
nummer drei ist dass wir uns wirklich
einfach mal fertig macht das ganze hier
und dann die schon was hier raus kommt
da kommt wenn ich jetzt mal rumlaufe
seht ihr hinter mir ist
ich bin hinter mir das ist nämlich ein
unsichtbarer hund riding von meinem
skull bei meinem kopf gucken kann man
hinter meinen maschke schauen denn was
brabus dahin bester darsteller auf na ja
also das ist der unsichtbare hund der
reitet dann irgendwie meinen kopf und
der verfolgte auch die ganze zeit ich
weiß nicht was es bringt aber ich bin es
eigentlich ganz witzig ob der computer
her der kleinen schau ist eine ganz
interessante sache dass man so etwas
auch machen kann das einfach mein kopf
nicht selbst reitet war sein ich mich
selbst reitet man kommt bereitet ein
hund und verfolgt mich selbst finde ich
ganz interessant wurde mir zugesendet
von sos 6er genau von der gleichen
person nummer 1 der command nummer eins
beendet hat und was hast du dazu
cornelius ey du musst mal ein buch lesen
roman nummer vier ist dieser command und
zwar hat es etwas mit luftballons zu tun
und zwar wenn ich einfach mal auf fertig
drücke ich habe jetzt ganz oft mal hier
drauf du gesehen da kommen ganz ganz
viele luftballons mehr oder weniger hat
er sie genannt und die fliegen jetzt
wirklich die ganze zeit einfach so rum
die solche behinderten und das coole
daran ist man könnte rein theoretisch da
sogar irgendwelche kloster unserer
einpacken dann hätte man quasi richtige
glühwürmchen die dann so rumfliegen
nachher zeit ist es dann auch so wie ihr
es hier seht da fallen dann einfach die
claims hin also die sie spielen
natürlich nicht jetzt das leben lang
darum der command hat natürlich auch
irgendwann ein ende
ihr wenn ihr das anschaut aber man kann
da rein theoretisch auch an stadthagen
clayton schreiben kannst du ja auch
irgendwie hin schreiben ja taktlos sonst
rein oder aktivierte redstone lampen und
dann leuchten die teile im dunkel das
ist mega cool und es wird schon wieder
macht dabei meinen entscheid mit dem
letzten mal wo es darum geht dass eine
komplette stadt erschaffen wird nummer 5
wurde mir zugesendet von minecraft von
einem amerikaner und zwar schreibt er
dass seine state buildings city wenn ich
jetzt hier einfach mal so durch die ihr
seht ihr schon da komme ich nicht zum
ende dieser command besitzt über 2.400
zeichen und ich habe ihn euch über pace
bin und in die beschreibung eingebaut
wenn ich jetzt einfach mal hier
draufklicken bekomme ich hier erst mal
so ganz viele commands hingesetzt das
bildet jetzt erstmal so ein kleines ding
das ist dann eine die streuung maschinen
da werden dann wieder command blogs
reingesetzt und wenn das ganze gleich
fertig ist bekomme ich einen schneeball
in die insel
da kommen ganz gut ab war und dass ich
den verarmten schnäbel habe hier ist ein
schneeball und der heißt create spd in
schneeberg jetzt beispielsweise einfach
mal die hinterseite schon city
der setzt sich hierhin kreiert jetzt
gleich zwei drei neue teile da sind
jetzt hauses beispielsweise und jetzt
wird einfach eine komplette stadt
errichtet heute das ganze ihr wisst es
war einfach ein verdammter command der
ist beim egal wo ich stecke ich in dem
hostel so sieht das ganze dann aus es
kommt auf eurem pc an wie schnell das
ganze fällig ist bei manchen pcs dort
vier minuten bei manchen pcs über meinem
dort 17 sekunden da steht doch jetzt
findet im chat drin und dann haben wir
hier war eine ganze cd die mit keine
ganze sie bestehen aus den häusern oder
so aber die wurde von einem command
gemacht und das extrem cool das ist auf
jeden fall mit einer der coolsten
commands e mail zugesendet wurden wenn
ihr auch solche kohlen commands kennt
und euch denkt hey ich hab noch nicht im
westen kommend ihnen die im internet
gefunden oder mir selbst ausgedacht oder
von einem kumpel oder so dann schreibt
sie mir in das commands formular was
hier oben in der beschreibung sind über
den link zu meinem facebook twitter
instagram ein mikro und ein paar anderen
sachen und dann will ich sagen will ich
meine bewertung freuen wenn es euch
gefallen hat und die mär von den command
wollen und wir sehen uns im nächsten
video wieder